では よろしくお願いします
先月も業についてお話をしましたが
まあそこから続けてお話ししなくちゃいけないんですけど
まあ皆様方はそれもう綺麗にお忘れになっていると思いますけど
まあ実を言うと私も何言ったか全部忘れていますから
まああまり問題ないと思います
この業というものはね
あの まあ日本でこの仏教の影響でよく知られていることで
日本の社会というのは仏教は嫌い悪いには文化はほとんど仏教の文化なんですね
ですから まあそれはまああるものは否定するという性格で
いえ 我々は違いますよと言ってありはしますけど
結局日本の文化っていうのは
まあ仏教文化の方がまあかなり70%仏教文化なんですね
で 残りといえば ちょっとしたお祭りぐらいとかね
まあそんなもんなんですよ
仏教以外のものは まあそういう仏教文化ですから
文化と宗教違いますよ
私は日本の社会は仏教文化だと言ったんだから
皆様強引に仏教徒にしてあげるわけじゃないんです
そうは思ってないんです
キリスト教の日本人であろうとも
文化は仏教文化なんです
宗教はまた別なものでね
文化っていうのは日々何考えて
どんな仕来り習慣をしながら
まあ家族関係 社会関係
そういうものはどのようにして生活しているかというところだからね
ですから たとえキリスト教を信仰している人であろうとも
日本人として生きていますからね
ですから文化は仏教文化なんです
まあ宗教は別で で ですから
この日本の文化である言葉で
この業というのは それからもう一つことありますね
因ですかね 縁と因ではなくて縁ですね
まあ因という言葉も使うし
縁という言葉も使うし
まあ業という言葉も使うし
ですから この文化として我々の日常の生き方に入っている言葉なんですね
だからといってそれをわかっているかというと
これわからないんですよ
もう業って何なのかと
だからいつでも私は言うのは
普通日本語で業といえば
なんか暗い感じで悪いことだけに使うんですね
業が悪いという言葉はあるんだけど
業が良いという言葉が日本語でないんですね
あの人の業が良いということは言わないんですね
業が悪いとは言いますね
縁起の場合は 縁起がいいと縁起が悪いと両方使ってます
そこは合ってますけど
縁起が悪いと縁起が良いとというところは正しく使ってますけど
業の場合は業が悪いというところだけ使っているんですね
で 業が悪いというならば
同じく業がいいということもあるはずなんです
で なんで業が悪いという言葉だけ使っているかというと
業といった途端 何か不幸
業イコール不幸という風になっていますね
その傾向もインドだ 日本だけじゃなくて
大体なんかそんな傾向でみんな考えてるみたいんですよ
日本以外にもね まあ業を信じている人々はたくさんいますからね
まあミャンマーであろうやらタイやら自分の国やら
またインドヒンドゥー教なんですけど
それでも業っていうのはまあ信じているし
まあどちらにしても何か悪い方に
ちょっと重く入れて考えるということはあるみたいだから
日本の考え方はそれほど正しくないよということは
あまり大きな声では言えないんです
で ここでこの業っていうのは
まあ誰かさんがこのインターネットにも書いてあったんだけど
これはまあインド ヒンドゥのインドの南で受け売り
受け 受け売りではないかとかね
で そういうのはまあ私はかなり混乱させる言葉なんですね
混乱ではなくて 私はかなり刺激させる言葉なんですよ
すごい怖いんです そういうことを言うと無責任で
一旦出家したら 普通の人間よりはちょっと考え方が違うということも理解してほしいんです
なかなか歯が立たないと思います
お釈迦様のおかげで お釈迦様が結局このインド人みんな業を信仰しているんだから
では私も信じてやるぞという
そんなけしからんなことをやったわけじゃないんです
インドで業の思想なかったんです
で この民間的に まあこれはどんな部族の人間でも
何かこれがやったら悪いんだよと
罰が当たりますよという考え方ぐらいはありますよ
これは森の中で原始的に裸で生活している部族であろうとも
ああ これはやってはいけませんとかね
こういうことをやってはいけませんよ
もう精霊が怒りますよとかね
神様が怒りますよと 罰が当たりますよとかね
そういう話はありますよ
信仰は だから当然 お釈迦様の時代でもその程度の考え方はありました
決して知識的な インテリ的な
すごい科学的というか
すごいこのまあ具体的な論理的な話ではなかったんです
ただ まあ今もこのもう裸で生活する人間がいるかどうか分かりませんだけど
まあそんな感じで部族生活している
森の中で生活している人々でも
もう罰が当たるんだよぐらいの考え方は持ってますから
それはそのまま はい 分かりました
私も信じますよという
そんな程度の程度の人間ではないんだよ
お釈迦様は 何一つも信じて信じないんですよ
証拠を探して 証拠に照らし合わせて
まあ法則を見つかる 見出そうとしているんですよ
で 例えば人が歩いていると
何かもう木の実一つ落ちちゃって
人が死んじゃったりしますね
それは大げさではないんですよ
日本ではそんな大きな木の実ないんだけど
自分の国だったらいくらでもありますけどね
ココナツ木ココナツ一つでも頭の上に落っこっちゃったら
まあそれで終わりますからね
ですから そういう木の下で歩いている時は
まあココナツの葉っぱ一枚落ちても死んじゃいますよ
ですから そこで見て やっぱりその人の業が悪かったと
で そんなふうなことをいい加減なことはもうお釈迦様は信仰はしません
言おうとも信じようともしません
そういうあらゆる出来事をケースを考察して
何か法則はありますかと
ですから やり方は現代科学のやり方と全く同じことで
まあこういうことをしたらこうなるんですよと
こういうことをしたらこうなるんですよ
それ何が法則ありますかと
法則って何なのかと この一定した普遍的な法則を見出そうとしているんですよ
そこでお釈迦様の業っていうのは
こういうもうあの もう山にいい加減に入ったら
山の神様が怒って罰が当たったとかね
あるいは人の日々の行いが悪いんだから
神が怒って洪水にして村人村を全部流して流せ
流してしまったとかね
そんなような考え方ではありません
親に逆らったんだから
子供はすごい病弱だよとかね
で  sex をしないんだからなかなか商売繁盛できませんよとかね
夫婦喧嘩は絶えませんよとか
そんな話は普通の人間には何の調子もなく言っていることですけど
そんなことは仏教で言っているわけじゃないんですね
ですから その人間の生き方って何なのか
もう幸福 不幸っていうのはどういう風になるものでしょうかとかね
そこは徹底的に調べて
普遍的な法則 科学的な法則を見出したんですね
で それが仏教の言論であって
ひとかけらも当時のブラフマン人から借りた考え方はないんです
カルマという言葉が似ているんだからといって
教えに似ているわけじゃないんです
輪廻も同じなんです 輪廻サンサーラという言葉はもうインドの言葉だから
これは誰も使ってますよ
だからといって仏教でいう輪廻という思想
考え方 それが誰からもパクったものではありません
ですから 仏教の思想 概念
すべてお釈迦様の発見なんです
それははっきりと証明できるんですよ
学問的に研究するならば
だから 学者の方々のいい加減にみんな言っていることは
このオウム返しで言うんじゃなくて
ちゃんとヴェーダ聖典も読んでもらって
ちゃんとウパニシャッドテキスト
バラモンテキストを読んでもらって
はっきりと言論ありますかと
仏教で語っているように研究してほしいところなんですけど
それをやらないんですね
でも引用はする 言葉だけ似ていると
ヴェーダ聖典にも業の話がありましたとかね
ヴェーダ聖典に業カルマという言葉は全然ないんです
あの膨大な聖典には だからまあ
ジャイナ教でもカルマという言葉がありますけど
私はそっちをジャイナ教という言葉を使いますけど
皆様は全然知らないんでね
ジャイナ教って何なのか
で 仏教を研究することをするならば
決して忘れることできない宗教なんですよ
なぜならば 互いにかなり影響し合っちゃったんです
ジャイナ教と仏教は それでお釈迦様もそれほど激しく批判しようとしなかったんです
お釈迦様に至っても ジャイナ教の場合はなんか心配するんです
たまに批判するんですけど
すごく親切に 君たちは間違ってるんだよと
という感じで説明したりするんですよ
ですから ある面で この弟子たちの間で結構交流があって
仲良くしたりもしましたし
お釈迦様のところに何のことなくジャイナの人々は来たりもするし
喧嘩もするし 当然ながら宗教は二つですからね
で まあ喧嘩するぐらいは一応交流があったんですね
そういうことで このジャイナ教っていうのは
この完全な非暴力主義
絶対的なアヒンサ語ってたんですよ
これが悪い考え方じゃないんですよ
絶対的に非暴力主義にならなくちゃあかんと
自分の体に住み着いている虫でも微生物でも
決して殺してはいけませんと
命は殺しては絶対いかなる場合でもあかんという
すごい徹底しているんですよ
だからお釈迦様にそれには何か一言言うことはできませんね
だから その人々が言っていることは
すごく社会に対してはすごくいいことで
ですから このあまり何も言わないんですね
文句は それでお坊さんたちはこの年一回
3ヶ月間 どこにも行かないで暗号というんですけど
暗号漢字がわかりません
もしかすると出されるかもしれません
で 一応受き  3ヶ月間どこにも行かないで
どこかにこもって修行するんですよ
それが最初はお釈迦様
あんまりそんなことしなくたっていいんじゃないかと
毎日いろんなところで歩いて説法する
修行したい人はいつでも一年中したい時はすればいいやと
一年中修行の時期っていうのはあるわけないという態度なんですよ
今日は修行によくない日ですよとか
そんな迷信は認めませんだからね
でもお釈迦様の弟子たちは
この五蘊もどう引けばいいんですかね
辞書あるんだけど ないね
ありました でも書けない
はい うん はい まあそういう感じ当ててますけどね
まあ雨の時は安らかにいるという意味ではないんですけど
かなり厳しく修行するんです
だからなんでそんな感じか私にはわかりませんですけど
正しいといえばね 雨の感じと行入れた方が良かったのにね
雨季行と入れた方が良かったのはね
のに まあこれは中国の偉い方々が作った言葉だから
だから単語は偉くないんです
そこでこのブッダの弟子たちはもう雨が降ってもあっちこち歩くんだから
この虫とかね まあ潰しちゃうんですよ
歩く時は インドの雨っていうのはものすごい豪雨で
もう止まることなくずっと続けて雨が降るみたいんですね
私はあまりわかりませんが
それでジャイナの人々はこの沙門の弟子たちがね
殺生ばっかりしやがっちゃって
あの雨が降ってる時でも一箇所に止まっていないんだ
動物さえ雨が降ると動物に入ってどこにも行かんではないかと
で いろいろ悪口を言うんですね
そう言えば まあそうでしょうと
で 言ってお坊さんたちにも
あなた方ももう雨季になったら一箇所に止まって修行修行しなさいと
もうそれだけの考えです
お釈迦様は ただ みんな一応ガチャガチャ言ってるんだから
まあ今は大変な行事として
初期仏教の国々で雨安居をやってますけど
もともとお釈迦様はすごい気楽に
だったら君たちももう雨季はまあどこにも行かないようになさいと
3ヶ月間  そういうふうに
この戒律の関係ではいろいろ影響を受けたことがあるんです
向こうは批判するとなかなか反論もできない場合は
まあそれはそのまま まあまあいいを守りましょうと
こちらでも でも仏教は
例えばジャイナ教はこの水には命があるんだと
と言うんですね 水には命があるんだから
水を飲んではいけないんですよ
殺生になるんです そんなことを言うと
ちょっとおかしいと 仏教はね
そこでまあ面白い それをバカにするために
仏教で出している例えなんですけど
まああるジャイナ教の人がお釈迦様と口論
口論ではなくて まあ一応ディスカッションして
水にはもうやっぱり命があるんだよ
どうやってあんたはそれを知ってます？と言ったら
たいまつを持ってね 誰かが川を渡ると
もし水がね たいまつのところにも入ってくると泣くんではないかと
たいまつの火が水の中に入ると何か音が出るでしょ
あるいは火がもうもう火に焼けますからね
命が泣いてるんではないか
だから人間も誰か火をつけちゃうと
体にもう痛いともう泣くでしょうね
だから水に命があるんだよと
そんな単純なことを言うかどうか
私もちょっとどうか分かりませんだけど
仏教は一応もうからかっていることは確かなんですね
ジャイナのその考え方は
で その代わりにお釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
比丘たちに決してこさないで水飲んではいけないんだと
だから必ずもどこに行っても水こしを持って行きなさいと言って
水を濾して飲む で それぐらいにしているんです
でないと何かちょっとやりきれないんですよ
水に命があるんだぞと言っちゃうと
確かに水には微生物とかはいるし
そんなのを飲んでしまえば
栄養になるどころじゃなくて
病気になってしまっちゃうし
だからまあ微生物も入っている水は飲まない方がもうありがたいことなんですけど
でも彼らがこの微生物のことではなくて
水そのものに命があると言ったんですね
そこで仏教はそれはちょっと変えて
水の中に生命がいるんだと
それはもういい加減に殺生してはいけないと
ということで水を濾して飲む
でまあ そういうふうな
まあそんなに大したことないんだけど
ちょっとつまらない つまらない戒律的なもう影響っていうのはあるんですよ
他の宗教からは全くももう影響を受けることはしない
例えばヒンドゥーバラモン教だったら儀式
儀礼 もう頑固と反対 動物を生贄とかしたりするし
神様にいろんなお供えをしてお祈りしたり
もう頑固と反対という立場をとるんですね
そんなのはもう綺麗さっぱりやめなさいと
あんた方は大儀式っていうのはわかる
わかりますけど 神にお供え物するんじゃなくて
自分の国の貧しい人々に豊かな人々は思い存分寄付しなさいよと
それこそ正しい儀式だよと
宗教的な儀式 儀礼だよと
というふうにすごい反対するんですね
ジャイナ教の場合は そういうことはあまり真っ向から反対するとはなかった
ですから いつでも仏教を語る
理解する場合は このジャイナ教にはしょっちゅう引用することにはなります
そこでジャイナ教でもカルマという言葉があります
ありますが それ 仏教のカルマではないんですよ
ジャイナ教はカルマというのは物質なんです
例えばこの机がカルマなんです
マイクロフォンもカルマなんです
物質だから でも我々が知っている業といえば
このガラスは業ですよという人はいないでしょうね
だから同じや似ているんだというふうな無責任なことを言っちゃうと困るんですよ
ジャイナ教は確かにカルマという言葉はしょっちゅう使っているんです
経典を見ると でもちょっとでも居眠りしながら読んだところで
仏教の業やと ちょっとダブっちゃうと
とんでもないことになってしまうんですよ
だから言葉が似ていても
内容は似ていないというところはあります
そこら辺は気をつけないと
勉強がちょっと変な方向へ行ってしまいますね
誤解の方向へ行ってしまいます
そこまで余計な話なんですけど
ですから 一応私はまとめて言いたいのは
お釈迦様がおっしゃった業についての話
それはお釈迦様自身が自分で悟って言っているものなんです
誰かから借りた考え方では全くありません
それで仏教の特色っていうのは
全て証拠を見て調べて
その中から法定式式というもの
法定式 それを出すことなんですよ
この方程式っていうのは普遍的で
正しい方程式を見いだしたら
それはいつでも有効なんですよ
わかりやすく言えば 例えば三角形の面積はどうやって計算するかと
もうあらゆる方法はあるかもしれませんよ
いろんな三角形を持ってきて
面積を知っている何か小さなものはどれぐらいで埋め込めるかとかね
計算したりとかね あるいは何かペンキ塗ってみるとかね
このペンキだったらこれぐらい何平方センチぐらい塗れますよと言って
三角形ぐらいに塗る場合はどれぐらいとかなんとかとか
そういう方法はあるんだけど
全部もう科学的な方法ではないんですよ
まあとにかくいろいろ工夫して
三角形の何でしたっけ
面積を計算する方程式っていうものを作るでしょ
それが普遍的で どんな三角形についても当てはまるんですよ
だから たとえ三角形が変わっても
大きさやいろいろ面積を計算する方程式は変わりません
そういうふうな感じで
仏教っていうのはほとんどそういうあらゆる方程式のリストなんですね
だから ほんのちょっと難しく感じる可能性もあります
それで我々説法するということはどういうことかというと
いろいろ方程式をまず出して
この方程式はどうやって成り立つものか
どうやって理解するものかで説明してあげることなんですね
だから 方程式だけではちょっとわかりにくい
そういうふうなことになっています
ですから 業についてもお釈迦様が一つの方程式を出しているんです
で この前も説明しましたからね
業っていうのは一応行為に結果があると
というまず普通な思考ですよ
もう物理学でもいう エブリアクションハスイツオンリアクションというね
リアクションがありますよと
だからリアクションなしに何も起こるわけじゃありませんね
物理的な世界でもあることで
当たり前なことで そこで仏教は物理には全く興味はない
興味あるのは心というエネルギーについてなんですね
で 心というエネルギーはエネルギーですから
いろんな行為をしています
例えば私が喋るということは
ただ口があるんだから喋っているわけじゃないんですね
心が働いているんですよ
で 心が働いて喋らせているんですよ
だから喋るというすごい行為なんですけど
それを本当にやらせているのは心なんですよ
私は立っているということをしていますよ
それは物理的な機能じゃありません
物理的だったら片足で立ったりすることもできませんだからね
体はそういうふうにできてないんだから
でも心が働き出しちゃって
もう片足でも立てる 体はそれなりに調節してくれる
本当に人間立つということは物理法則には違反ですよ
でも立ってるでしょうに
誰もあまり気にしないんだけど
すごい不思議なんですよ
体重は全部上にあって
重さが全部上にある それに全然バランス整えないで
ほんの小さな足で小さな面積で立っていること
それで一本の足で立って
もう一本の足が上がったり横にしたりする
それも誰でもできますよ
では 人形を全く体の大きさに重さに作って
人形の足一本伸ばしてみてください
倒れちゃいますよ だからまるっきり物理学には合ってないんですよ
我々ただ単純に立つということさえも
ですから それはある特別なエネルギーが働いていますね
立たせているんです 心で
例えば 立っている人がそのまま寝てしまっちゃえば
体が倒れるでしょうに
電車に乗ったらえらい迷惑ですからね
しっかり座っていられますけど
寝てしまえばもう隣の人の体に乗り上がっちゃいますからね
ですから この立つことは物理的な働きやというならば
何で寝ていた？寝た人は立てないんですかね
そういうことだから はっきりとこの意識が
心が立たせているということはわかるんですよ
そういうことで 心っていうのはエネルギーなんですね
そこもいろんな行為をしている
だったら行為に結果があるということは当たり前のことなんですよ
リアクションというのはあるのは当たり前のことなんです
心の働きだけにはリアクションがありませんと
物質的な働きにはリアクションがあります
で言ったっても これはおかしい話で
そういうことですから
このどんな行為も必ずしも結果出す
というところからであるならば
心も行為をしている ですから
その行為にも結果がある
物質的なエネルギーのリアクションというのは
誰にでもわかることで
ちょっと調べれば で それには業という言葉を使ってないんです
で 心のこのアクションとリアクションの関係は
業という言葉を使っているんです
で そこは仏教で言っている業ということなんですね
ですから まあ難しいんですけど
そんなにこの信じられないんだと
変な話ではないかということはできないと思います
私はわかりません だからそんなのは信じませんというのは
まああんまりかっこよくないと思います
みんなよくよく威張っていますけど
そんなのはもう今更わかるわけないんで
それは捨てちゃえばどうですかとか
その考え方なんかは なんであんた方は伝統的に信仰しているんですか？とかいうのは
本人がかっこいいこと言ってるつもりですけど
えらいかっこ悪いんですよ
言ってるのは私がわからないんだから正しくないっていうことだからね
そういうわけで 仏教の話
すべてわからなくても
これはしょうがないんですよ
だからといって正しくないということは言わないで
方程式を発見して なるほど
その方程式はわかりますよと
もう内容はわからないんですよと
ふうにしてもらわないと
それからあの まあそれから仏教の中身の業に時間もなくずっと回りますからね
で 話に入りますけど まず業についてお釈迦様が言っていることは
これは人間の知識で把握できるものではありません
まずそれを言っているんです
できれば考えないで放っておいてくださいと
人間の知識では把握できるものではありませんと
それぐらい複雑で難しいんだよと
もし人間が普通の理屈で
普通の常識で あれやこれやと業について考えたっても
まず頭が狂って間違ってしまいます
狂っちゃいます と言っています
はっきりと 混乱して狂ってしまいますよ
ですから お釈迦様にしてみれば
我々お釈迦様がおっしゃった正しい生き方
修行 良い人間になる方法
そういうものを実践してもらえば
それでいいんじゃないかなと
業は何なのかとか 輪廻っていうのは本当にあるかとかね
そんな踏ん張っても もういくら膨らませても
あのカエルとカエルのお母さんと牛の話知ってますね
そんな風になっちゃうんですね
知らない方々にさっさと言いますけど
カエルの子供が散歩に行ったところで牛一頭見たんですよ
見たらあまりにも大きさに驚いちゃって
もう動物かなんか生き物やと分かったんだけど
怖くて逃げちゃったんですね
逃げてお母さんのところに行ったら
お母さんが子供よりはすごい体が大きいんだからね
お母さんに言うんですよ
ものすごい大きい動物がいたんだよと
大きいってどれぐらいですかねとお母さんちょっと威張ってね
子供でしょ 自分の子供だからね
自分の方が力強いこと大きいっていうことを言いたいんだからね
大きいって言ったら そんなもう怖がらなくていいんだよと
どれぐらい大きいと思いますかと
これぐらいとお母さんが体膨らませて見せるんですね
そしたら子供が いえ もっと大きいんですけどと
そしたらもうちょっと膨らませたんですね
でも子供は いえ もっと大きいんだよと
で もっと膨らませて見せたんですね
それで膨らませて 膨らんでお腹が破裂して死んでしまったんですよ
だから カエルのお母さんがいくら膨らませても
自分の体はね 牛の大きさにはなりません
そういうことだから この我々人間の知識
能力レベルでは いくら踏ん張っても
あまりにも想像を絶する巨大な業の機能は把握できないと
ということを言ってます
おっしゃってます ということは
お釈迦様の気持ちとしては
そんな話はちょっと置いておいて
あんた方は自分に理解できるところで修行してみたらどうですか
きちんと結果が出ますよと
悟り開けますよと それだったら
すべての問題はそこで解決やと
というところはやっぱり強調しているんです
ですからはっきり言うと
業の話っていうのは余計な話なんです
まず難しいことを理解してほしい
次に ではお釈迦様はどうやってそれを知ったんでしょうかというと
お釈迦様は修行によって
我々のこの五感だけに迫る
なんています 限られている
この智慧をもうものすごい破っちゃったんですね
我々の知識っていうのは
五感の情報にだけ限っているんですね
全然法則どころか 宇宙レベルで物事を見ることができないんで
それをお釈迦様が修行によって破って
ものすごい超越した知識
能力というか 情報を取る方法が身についたんですね
ですから お釈迦様が言うのは
知ろうとするならばどこまででも知り得ると
見ようとするならば どこまででも見えると
ということをおっしゃっているんですね
で もし人がお釈迦様がなさった同じ修行をして
もし我々でも 我々のこの五感に限られている小さな知識レベルを
その壁を破るならば とても簡単にわかるんです
とても簡単というのはちょっと失礼ですけど
ああ こういうことかと
いくらかわかります 例えば
宇宙ってどんなもんか
私さっぱりわからないでしょうに
どれほどで どれほど巨大で
どういうものかさっぱりわかりません
でも 誰かがアストロノートって何でしたっけ？日本の語で
宇宙飛行士が何かスペースシャトルでも乗って
まあ一応地球の軌道ぐらいに行って
空なんか見ると もうなんとなくわかるでしょ
おそらく すごい大変な世界やと
でも その人も宇宙のすべてわかったわけじゃないんですよ
上下関係ない世界ってどんな感じ？我々
我々にいつでも下あるでしょうね
宇宙に行ったら下がないんだから
この下という状況ない状況って何なのかということは
ちょっと 地球の軌道にでも行かないとわからないもんなんですよ
だからといって宇宙の巨大さわかるわけでもないんですね
そんなもんで 我々はこの次元をちょっと破ってもらうと
あ なるほど こういうことかとはわかる可能性はあります
それもポイントとして覚えておいてください
業の話は決して日常生活の常識から語っているものではないんです
超越した智慧からおっしゃっているものなんです
だからそんな智慧はインドではまあお釈迦様にしかなかったし
だからブッダの独特 独特の教えなんです
では次に これからブッダが我々に何とか理解できるところで説明したところ
説明していきます あの業っていうのは結果のことだから
我々はそれ気になるんですよ
例えばお腹が空いたらお腹が空いたということは
物理的なことで この機械にエネルギーがなくなったということで
そんな困る人がいないんですよ
それには何か食べればいいんです
眠くなったと あ 困ったと
そんな困る人はいませんね
眠くなったら寝れば済むことで
体のことというのは単純ですよ
体が汚れたと まあどうったことない
もう洗っちゃえばいいと
で 毛が薄くなったと 別にどうったことないんですけどね
どうしてもかっこ悪いと思うんだったら
カツラでもつければいいでしょうに
でもそれにえらい困ってる人もいますけどね
で 歯が抜けたと まあ入れ歯入れちゃえばいい
もうそれで済むもんでしょうに
あー困った どうしようかとかね
ですから この体のことについては
我々はあんまりそんなに困りません
でも 自分の性格によってなかなかうまくいかないとかね
いい人間になりたいんだけど
なかなかいい人間にはなれないんだと
で 幸福にもなりたいんだけど
いつでも何か起きて もう何かもううまくいかないんだと
不幸は連続してくるんだと
どうしようかと そういうところで人間が確かに困るんですよ
ちょっとした出来事は気にしませんだけど
この連続して不幸は次から次へと来ると
仕事はしたいんだけど
もうどうももう雇ってくれないんだと
資格もあるし もうなんかどうかでもう雇ってくれないとかね
どうかで何か原因がある
自分でもわからない 時々自分よりも資格は
同じ面接に行っても 相手の人が自分よりも資格の方が少ないかもしれませんだけど
もう選ばれている 内定されていて
自分はなしと その場合は何かどこかで納得いかないし
これはどういうことでしょうかとかね
で 考えたり困ったりする
それから原因も見いだせないんですね
原因知ってるんだったら何とかできますけどね
そういうふうに私たちは
なんかどこかで困るところは確かにありますね
結婚したいんだけどと思って
もう誰か見つけて結婚したら
なかなか性格が合わないんだと
ひどい人と一緒になったと
それで踏ん張ってその人から別れる
別れたらやっぱり寂しい
誰かと一緒にならないといけないんだと思って
また誰かを探して結婚する
再婚する そしたら まあ摩訶不思議に前の人と同じ性格なんですね
それで3番目になっても
やっぱり自分には相手を見る目がないんだとかね
なんでどうして私はこういう人ばっかり選ぶんでしょうかとかね
自分選ぶんだけど なんでそういう合わない人選ぶんでしょうかとかね
で そういうところでは本当に困るんですよ
答えがないんだから 業が関わり持つのはそこら辺なんですよ
いわゆる物理的に変化できるならば
業は関係ないんです 例えば
どこかの会社に入りたいんですけど
会社はやっぱり １９０センチでなければいけませんと
身長はといったところで
自分が今日測ったところでやっぱり１７０ですねとかね
はい 分かりました 明日の面接に１９０センチに身長を伸ばしていくぞと言って
ぐっと足と頭を引っ張って１９０になったところで
はい  OK やとそこでストップとできますかね
これは無理でしょう で
体重ぐらいは踏ん張っていくらか減ることはできますけど
でも生まれた時からの例えば体重がある人が２５歳でもう例えば１００キロぐらいに１５０キロぐらいやると
それで会社で我々は本当は４５キロだったら雇いますよと
この人は一生踏ん張っても４５キロにはならんでしょうね
これだけ測ってみたっても
もう飛んでますからね
それはどう説明してどう解決できるかと
このネクタイはダメですよと
制服ではこの会社では雇いませんよと言ったら
もう日本の和服に入れ替えれば簡単ですよ
それは困る問題じゃないんですよ
うちの会社はもうみんな頭を剃ってなきゃダメですよ
では髪の毛剃っちゃえばいいんだからね
あるいはうちの会社はみんなこの色を
何といいますか 脱色して金髪にしているんだと
あんた髪の毛黒いんだから雇うわけにいきませんと言ったら
その人はでは髪の毛を金髪だったら雇ってくれますかと
いいですよと言ったら
では明日来ますよと そのまま床屋行って髪の毛金色にしちゃえばいいでしょうに
だから物理的な変化っていうのは
業の世界ではありません
とても簡単なことで どう踏ん張ってもそう簡単に変化できないところはみんな困り果てるんですよ
そういう世界は一応業という因果法則にした方が
まあもしかすると合っているかもしれません
業は不思議な不可思議なことではないので
単なる因果法則なんです
アクションにリアクションがある
だから身長が短いという場合は
それ結果でしょ その結果
作った原因でしょ 例えばもう人付き合いはすごく悪いんだと
誰としゃべったっても
なんか雰囲気がすごく悪くなっちゃうんだと
その人のそれ結果でしょ
上手に言葉喋れません
言ってはいけないことすぐ言ってしまうと
そこであ まずいこと言ったんだよといくら後悔しても
今度はしっかり昨日聞いた話するぞと言っても
現場になってくるとまたまずいことを言ってしまっちゃうんですね
それは結果なんですね
では いつでも人付き合いが悪くて
まずい言葉を喋ったり
悪いやってはいけないことしたりする
その性格ってどうやって成り立ったんでしょうかと
母に聞いてもわからへんでしょうね
お母さんに聞いても なんでこういう性格になったんでしょうかと
わからないと思いますよ
お母さんに言えば お前は昔からもそういう性格でしたよと
それしか言えないんです
生まれた子には 例えば何か体の部品が欠けているとしますね
それでその子が喋るようになって
何でお母さんが私には何か部品が欠けて欠けているのではないかと
他の子供たちについているものは
母がどう答えればいいんですかね
母に言えるのは まああんたは生まれる時もそういうふうに生まれたんだよと
その世界ですよ 仏教で業っていうところで扱っているのは
それはすべてこの心が作る原因ですよと
DNA の説明ではうまくいかないんですよ
で なぜかというと このDNAの文言と言ったっても
これは噛み合わせて命にするのは心なんですね
DNA を合わせて命にするのは心なんですよ
心が自分で あ これとこれといいやと決めちゃうと
だから我々はいろんな遺伝子持ってますよ
いろんなもうたくさん持ってますけど
ある一部だけで組み合わせて
もう体が構成しちゃうんですね
まあそういう風になってるんです
ですから この生まれる瞬間でね
まあ仏教で生まれるということは
おなかの中で このえっと
精子と卵子が一緒になったらもう人間ですよ
DNA がくっついたらもう細胞個ですけど
もう人間なんです ユダヤ教では生まれるまでは人間ではありません
これジャイナ教じゃないんです
あのヨーロッパのユダヤ教では
で まあそれは関係ないんですけど
一応仏教の場合は このもう DNA 組み合わせたらもうもう人間です
で その瞬間でも心が働くんですと
命ですからね だから今更文句言ったってもね
文句言いたければ  DNA の組み合わせの時はこれで嫌やと
もっと身長がある もっとすごいかっこいい男
あるいはすごい美しい女性で
そうやって頭もいい そういう DNA 合わせてほしいやと
短命ではダメですよと
と今更言っても まあね
でも来世は期待できますよ
ここで死んじゃってまた生まれ変わる場合はしっかり判断して
しっかりした生命になるんだぞと
今から心しっかりしておくと
まあ来世は期待できます
だから今もいい加減で
どうでもいい感じで生きてるでしょうに
だったら来世もどうでもいいところで生まれ変わりますよ
そういうところでお釈迦様は
このどうでもいい感じで生きることはものすごい厳しく戒める
一つ一つの行為はすごい責任持って判断して行動しなさいと
そうすると頭がいつでもしっかりするんだと
物事を判断して これはやる
これはやりませんと これはこういうわけでやりません
これはこういうわけでやりますと
試しに自分の家で普通に歯ブラシ置くこと
歯磨き置くこと タオルを置くことでも
ちょっと考えて こういうわけでこちらに置いておく
こういうわけで これをこちらに置いておくと
試しにやってみてください
どれほど頭が良くなるかと
でもまあ こうやって言いますけど
私はやってませんです
いい加減ですけど そこら辺は
で でもそれやってみたっても
ものすごい頭が鋭くなるんです
そういうことで 我々は日々やっている
すごい小さな小さな行為についても
ちゃんと理解して判断して訳があってやる
そうすると心がすごく管理して整理されちゃって
しっかり強くなって そういう人がまあ何でも管理している性格だから
次に生まれ変わる時でもきちんとした整理されて管理されたシステムになるんですよ
新しいシステムが生まれる時は
生まれ変わると大げさじゃないんですよ
一つのシステム壊れて別なシステムが成り立つだけのことで
我々生命というよりはシステムと言った方がいいんですよ
物理的なシステムと心のシステム２つついているだけで
それは壊れたら別なところでまた別なシステムがその代わりに現れるんですよ
だから元のシステムがむちゃくちゃだったら
そのシステム壊れると生まれてくるシステムはむちゃくちゃなシステムになるんです
まあそれぐらいのことで
このあんまりもこのもう宗教的で
この世間の考え方を受け受け取って生まれ変わるんでしょうかとか
そういうふうに考えちゃう
そんなことってちょっと誤解しちゃうんです
そういうことではなく
単純で まあ一つのシステムが壊れて
別なシステムが現れたと
だからシステム一つ壊れると別なシステムになるんです
例えば動物一つ死んじゃとしますね
それは我々はどこかに捨てちゃうというかね
埋葬しておくと そうするとそっちのシステム壊れたでしょうね
そちらのアミノ酸やらいろんなものはそれなりに土に戻るでしょうに
別なシステムになる それは物質物質的なことで
で 簡単にわかるでしょうね
で 心もそうやって一つのシステムですね
例えばこの犬は埋葬したところで
あの花の種を植えたんだから
犬が花として生まれ変わったわけじゃないんだ
それはまるっきり別なことで
犬は別なところに行っちゃいますけど
あれは体が体の栄養分は植物に吸収されたっていうことは正しい
それは体の栄養分  そういうふうなことで
この我々は業と扱うべきものは
普通の科学的な思考で
普通の物理的な説明でどうにもならないところなんです
全く説明つかないところ
例えば百七十センチ身長があるそうと言ったら
医者がもうどういうふうにも足の骨はこれセンチやと
背骨は一個一個これぐらい長さありますよと
それであんたはこれぐらいと説明できるんだけど
なんで百七十？と聞いたら説明ないんですね
言えるのはあなた百七十センチ
それはまあこういう こういうところは
こういうこういうセンチ
こういうミリでもうできてできてますよというところで終わります
それは物理的な説明で
そこで子供が一人の子供が
なんでお兄ちゃんが百七十で
なんで私はもう百六十ですか？と聞いたって
もう医者はもうどう言えばいいんでしょうかね
それはもう説明つかない
つかない これからも では
DNA でうんうんや説明して
なんでそうなるんですかと聞いたら
例えばがんなんかは DNA の問題でがんになるんだよと今言ってるでしょうに
そうするとその DNA 入れ替えればもうがんを治りますよと
まあそれは正しいんです
説明も発見していますからね
まだ治療法は広げてないんですけど
一応治療法も可能だとは言ってます
で 聞きたいのは なんで私に
そういうがんになる DNA 入ったんですかと
だって両親の DNA の中でいっぱい DNA あるあるのに
なんでとか それは説明がないんですね
それでみんな言いたいのは
それはアクシデント 偶然
偶然というのはまるっきり非科学的な愚か者の考え方なんですよ
わからんと平気で言っちゃえばいいのに
頭がいい人はわからないと言うんですよ
頭が悪い人はそんなのは偶然だよと平気で言うんです
偶然っていうのは成り立たないんです
ちゃんと原因があってなるんですよ
偶然でも 例えばこの光が
ランプが花束になったら
これが偶然ですよ そうならないでしょうに
もしかするとこれがいきなり爆発するかもしれませんよ
ガラスが割れてボーンと音を出して
あ 偶然だと それは偶然じゃないんです
他のランプはそのままあるのに
なんでこれだけ爆発したんですかと
やっぱり偶然だ 今までこの会社作ったランプを一つも爆発したことがないんだとかね
そんなこと言ったっても
それは無知な考え方で
偶然には物事は起きません
原因があって起こるんですよ
例えば雷が あまり日本ではないんですけど
雷があっちこっち鳴っちゃうと
突然自分の家でいくつかの電気機械が壊れたと
それでその人は雷が家の電線に入ったならば
全ての電気機械壊れるはずなのに
なんでこれとこれだけはと
これが偶然だと 冗談じゃないんですけどね
そんなにもそれなりのちゃんとした原因があってそうなるんですよ
だから我々仏教では そこは業という
この心の反応で説明して説明しようとしているんですね
だから もし私の体にがんになる DNA ができているんだったら
それが偶然というわけじゃないんです
そういうことで あの業って何なのかというと
まず科学的には全く説明はつかないものの因果法則を語っているんです
だから だからといって科学的でないと言ったら
すぐみんな宗教的にして
神を信じる世界にしちゃうんですよ
それは神の道っていって人間知るものじゃないんだと
科学者にわかるわけじゃないんだと
そういう話は僕はしません
それも科学なんですけど
科学的な我々の思考ではもう管轄外で説明はできない
ただそれだけで でも 業そのものも科学なんです
管轄外だからわからないだけで
そういうことだから 我々一般人がどう理解するかというと
科学で説明つかないものは業の業のせいにしちゃえば
簡単じゃないんですかね
でも業のせいにしたらいいんだけど
業っていうのは不幸という意味じゃないんですよ
運命だから それは幸福
不幸両方あるんです 兄弟で一人がすっごい美しい人で
売れっ子で すごい金持ちになっていて
一人がまったくかっこ悪くて人気は全然ないといったいう場合は
それは科学的に説明しなさいと
科学的に説明できないんですよ
それで美しく すごく売れて
すごい豊かになっている人は
それはその人の業で なかなかもうあまり人気がない体格になった人は
それはその人の業でっていうふうにした方が
まあまあ それでまあ簡単に済むでしょ
問題は はい まあそこまでまあまあよく理解したという推測過程で次にいきます
それから この業はどのように理解すればいいかという
ちょっとある疑問がお互いに喧嘩がではなくて
このあるお坊さんからね
人が質問して それは質問が良くないということで
聞いた 聞いたのはこのジャイナ教の人なんですけど
あの 故意にというか 意識的に人間が行動すれば
どんな感覚を受けますかと聞いたら
そのお坊さんは苦しみを受けますよと
ただ 質問した人は全然認めないんですね
認めないで もう違いますよと言って帰っちゃったんです
お坊さんもちょっと納得いかないで
そこをお釈迦様に報告されたんですね
お釈迦様は叱ったんですよ
もういい加減なことをあんた方は無責任で答えるんだよと
で その質問した人は 私はお釈迦様からこういうふうに聞いているんだよとも言ってますけど
お釈迦様は私 その人に会ったこともないんだと
でもあなたの答えは間違っているんだよという一つ経典があります
えーと で この邪教の異教の人が
聞いた質問は 体の行為は意味が結果がない
言葉の行為も結果がない
心の働きにのみ結果があるんだよと
と釈尊が言っているんだと
そこ難しいんだから一応省略します
すごく難しいところです
で あのお釈迦様がその他の宗教家には会ったこともないと
会ったこともないんですが
あなたの答えも間違ってるんだよと言って
そこら辺説明します これからはいろいろ専門用語を使わないと説明できなくなりますけど
あの 仏教でヴェーダナという言葉があるんです
ヴェーダナっていうのは感覚という意味なんですね
感じること これが仏教では随分真剣に扱ると扱う言葉なんです
ものすごい重大な ポイントなんです
命っていうのは何なのかと
じゃあ科学的に定義しなさい
しなさいと言ったらできますかね
お医者さん プロがいくらでもいるでしょう
人のあの この人死んだんでしょうとか判断しなくちゃいかんでしょうに
では命ってわかってますかね？診断するために
すごい大事なことなんですけど
世の中の哲学では 科学ではいろんなものに定義があります
四角って何なのか 三角って何なのかってすぐ定義出しますよ
みんな 科学はもう定義ばっかしの世界でしょうに
では 命の定義ないんですね
定義しないで 生命の誕生はこういう風になりましたとか
もういきなり生命という言葉はライフという言葉を使ってます
そこにちょっと考えてほしいんですよ
例えば地球で初めてこういう風なことがあって
こういう風なことがあって
それで生命が誕生して
それからどんどんどんどん進化して
こういう風になって 今はこういう風になっているんだと
その説明は歴史だけは言いますけど
それも推測で それが通りかどうか分かりませんですけど
生命がこのように誕生しましたという場合は
生命って何なのかとまず定義しておかないと
使ってはいけないんですよ
言葉はそれであんまり延々必要ないんですけど
一応定義はありません
それで仏教は定義しています
命は命について語っているんだから
で 命っていうのはこのヴェーダナ感覚ということなんです
で それで私の体っていうのは明らかに純粋に物体なんです
なのに何かが違う 純粋な物体なんですけど
何かが違う 何かが違うというと
この外の世界を感じているんですよ
机も純粋な物体なんですよ
純粋な物体なんですよ
机がこのランプが電気がついているかいないか
今日は暑いかないか そんなのは全然関係ない
感じない お腹が空くこともない
感じないんですよ 汚れたっても全然感じないんですね
だから この体という物体と机という物体の
存続する方法が違うんですよ
机がそのまんま汚れたら汚れたままで
古くなったら古くなったままで
それでゆっくりと壊れていく
体が違うんですね お腹が空いた
喉が渇いた 疲れた もういろんな感覚があるんですね
その感覚があるんだから命というんですよ
感覚っていうのは秘密ではありません
だから命っていうのは秘密ではありません
はっきりしているものです
目を開けたら 目で色やら形やら感じてしまう
耳で音を感じてしまう
それに反応する 感じちゃったんだから
反応は業なんです 舌にいろんな味感じる
それに反応する 体で疲れた
お腹が空いた 喉が渇いたと感じる
感じたら反応する 喉が渇いたと感じたら
もう水を飲み 飲み込んだりする
お腹が空いたと思ったら食べたりする
それで食べたものは口で感じるでしょ
硬いなと思ったら何かする
芋を食べてみようかなと
あ これちょっと硬いと
そしたらもう焼いて食べると
感覚ですよ だから猿は芋は生で食べて
人間がそのまんまではなくて焼いて食べる
焼き芋を食べる と 命の営みでしょ
どうやってそれを成り立たせるか
って感覚なんです 猿ももしかすると焼き芋も食べると思いますけど
もうできんだからね 焼き芋を作ることはできないんだから
そのまま食べるしか方法ないんですよ
人間ができるんだから
もう焼き芋にして食べると
そうやって人間やってるあらゆる生命
やってるあらゆる行動
行為っていうのは この感覚から発生するんです
考えることも感覚から発生するんですよ
哲学も宗教も文化も 何から何まで
そこは命の関係あるものでしょ
だから命の定義っていうのは
感覚があるかないかということですね
物体に感覚があると命であって
物体に感覚がない場合はただの物体なんです
みんな魂があるんだと勘違いしているのも感覚なんです
魂があると思う 信じる
それはもう感覚でしょ？心の
そういうわけで 仏教はヴェーダナーという言葉をすごく大事に使ってます
ヴェーダナーの意味は感覚
それで生命って何なのかというと
ヴェーダナーが生命なんです
ただのヴェーダナー ただの感覚が生命なんですよ
何にも面白くないんですよ
不思議というよりは 例えば
体あちこち痒くなるでしょうね
あれ 感覚でしょ？それが命なんですよ
全然面白くないでしょうに
痒くなったとかね ちょっと腰が痛くなったとかに
そう 全て感覚なんですよ
ちょっと暑いと そういう単純な日常
ずっともう死ぬまで変化しながら変化しながら変わっていく
その感覚の流れが命というものなんですよ
面白くないんです 不思議もないんです
わかりにくいと言ったら
自分は何のこともない
すぐわかります それに納得いかないというところがバカというんで
仏教は簡単に 無知だと
偉そうにすごいことを考えるそう思っているのね
もうこれはもう もうどうにもならんと
この愚かさはどうにもならんと
だからすごい論理的で
もう感覚が命であると
それで科学者は物質と戦ってますから
仏教はの業の話では物質ではなくて
科学で説明できない 科学は未だに見ようとし
見ようともしていなかった生命の定義について話しているんですね
感覚について だから業はそちらに引っかかっちゃうんです
ヴェーダナーに引っかかっちゃうんです
だから業は知りませんよとは言えないと思いますよ
感覚ないんですかね 感覚が知ってるんだったら
業も知ってるはずなんです
仏教の業はね まあ例えばもう 30 分ぐらい座っていられない人がいますね
あちこち痛くて痛くて
その人の感覚なんです
その人の業なんですよ
こういう話なんかは もう 2 分聞くと
もうグーグーと寝る人もいるかもしれませんよ
感覚なんですね 聞くと
どんどん刺激を受けて面白い感覚が生まれるならば
もう 3時間でも聞いていられます
次から次へと面白い これも面白い
これも面白いと まあ １分以内で面白くない
もう聞きたくないと思っちゃうと寝ちゃうんです
それも感覚なんです だから業なんですよ
あの人はずっと勉強 仏教の話を聞いてるんだけど
全然わかってないんだそうだ
頭が悪いんだよ 業が悪いんだといろいろこという
まあ業ですよ あの人は話は 2回しか聞いてないんだけど
すごい分かっているんだそう
やっぱりその人はその人の業で
感覚で だから人の話を聞くとどんどん面白くなって
何だろう 何だろうとかね
もうそういう感覚が生まれると
言ったことはわかるし
そこで あの 何でしたっけ
アトピーとかの人々いるでしょ
乳製品が牛乳などが体に触れたらもうすごい病気になっちゃうとか
あるいは卵食べない 食べられない人はいるし
白いご飯食べられない人もいるしね
そういういろいろ食べ物にアレルギーを持ってる人々がいますね
その人の業でしょうに
卵が入っているものを食べると
ものすごい体が反応を起こして
もうもうあちこち膨れ上がって赤くなって
かゆくなって 目も赤くなる
大変なことになる場合があります
命にも命にも危険になる場合もありますよ
他の人 卵食べて何のこともない
それは何なのかというと
ある人が卵食べた あ 美味しかった
それで終わっちゃう その感覚で
あの人の体ではそういうことじゃなくて
すごい厳しい痛い感覚を作り出しちゃうんですね
だからその人は一生そういう食べ物を食べないでいい
良い感覚を味わいたければ
楽しい感覚を味わいたければ
一生そういう食べ物を食べないで気をつけなくちゃいけない
そこでこの電気の電波
波動であります それにもアレルギーを起こす人々がいますよ
そういう人がいると もう現代世界ではなかなか生きていられない
そういう人の話もいくつか何人かのケースを聞いたことはありますけど
まあいつでも病気で 体がもう変で
もうもう生活できなくて
もう病気で病気でたまらんと
それで調べれば調べると
この電線から出す磁場
それが体に反応を起こすと
その場合は全部家をもう全く新しく電線引くんですよ
磁場が外に出ないように
全部完璧に そうすると家の中でも電気製品
どうしても現代時代使うなくちゃいけないんだから
電話のコードにもプロテクターを入れておくと
だからそうやってすごいお金かかるでしょうし
人の家に好き勝手に行って
入ってパーティーやったりすることもできないでしょうに
それで これは神様 この人はなんでこうなったんでしょうかと
こういうふうにみんないろんなことを考えますけど
まあ業ですよ 感覚だから
その人の体はそういうふうに感覚ができちゃって
あるものには強烈に反発する
ということなんです だから
まあ結婚するのも業でしょうし
しょうがないんですよ
自分の感覚でこの人をいいと決めちゃうし
それからうまくいかなくなっても
まあ私は知ったことじゃないんですね
そのその人の業でしょうしね
そういうことで 仏教でこの業っていうのは
もの感覚に厳密に関係あることにしているんです
そういうふうに考えると
仏教でいう業っていうのは神秘的な話ではなくて
淡々としたすごい具体的な
お医者さんが体のことを説明するような感じで
はっきりした話じゃないんですかね
これはブラフマン教の業の受け入れとかね
言うともう怒りたいんだけど
もう足らないんですよ
怒っても私は だから怒りません
あまりにももう侮辱もいいところなんです
で この裸で生活している森の人間が
この山の神様を怒らせたらダメです
それがもうそんな話の引き続きだと言っちゃうと
これあまりにも侮辱なんですよ
だから仏教でいう業っていうのはしっかりしたもう科学そのものなんです
命はなんなのかというと
感覚で感覚は命であると
そこで感覚はいろんな変化するんですね
いろんなものに触れて
新しい感覚が生まれる
例えば 今 私のこの指がちょっと痒くなったんですけど
それは感覚でしょうね
それで私はこの指で違う感覚を入れるんですよ
もう書くっていうことはそういうことだからね
違う感覚を入れると 前の感覚はなくなって
別な感覚が生まれる それは痒みではないんだから
もう治ったということでやめるんですね
それが命なんです 業も同じことなんですよ
例えば 体が痒くて喋れなくなっちゃって
かいでかいでかいでかいてかいて
もうどうしようもなくなっちゃって
混乱しちゃってしまっちゃうと
もう業なんですよ でも
人の前にしゃべる前に立ってしゃべる場合は
時々人がいますね 人の顔を見た途端
なんか体震えちゃう 用意しているんだけど
しゃべるものをなんだかんだでも
でも なんとかもう喋れなくなっちゃうんです
何ですか あれは あれも感覚でしょ
だから業なんですよ 人の形が目に映った途端
なんか怖い 自信がないという感覚が作っちゃうんです
だからどうにもならないんだ
そういう人の場合は 目から入るんだから
目を隠して まずしゃべることは訓練させて
話すところに舞台に来る前に目を隠して持ってきて
目を隠したままではしゃべってくださいと頼むしか方法ないんですよ
そうするとしゃべるでしょ
おそらく その場合は見えませんだから暗記してもらわないと
体震えることなく だからそういうことっていうのは
我々のはそう簡単には変えられませんね
例えば肉食べたらもう下痢になっちゃって
じんじんと言うんですか
なんかかゆくなるんですね
皮膚が そういうふうな人っていうのは
そう簡単には治らないでしょうに
一番いい方法っていうのは食べないことなんです
それから地理的にも住めない場所があるんですね
人には みんなそうじゃないんだけど
いますね 時々寒いところでいたら
もう体が壊れて病気になってどうにもならない
だからその人にはしょうがないんですよ
暑いところに引っ越するしか
暑いところで全く生活できないという
ペンギンなんかはね 雪やもうそういうところ
寒いところで なきゃ生活できない
で 例えば都会でね こういう廃棄がいっぱいあるところで
もう肺がやられる人々もいますね
気管支やら肺やら でも感覚でしょ
だからその人は東京都の全ての車を止まってもらうか
車のない非自然の空気があるところに引っ越しするか
どちらかでしょう そういうことで
そう簡単には我々の人格っていうのは変わるということもないんです
だから この肌が肌の色が嫌やと言ってね
これが変えようとするよりは
自分に適した環境を作って
その苦しみから脱すれば
すごい科学的で合理的じゃないんですかね
例えば体質的に養殖食べるとものすごくコレステロールが出てきて
もう血圧も高くなって
まあ心臓に負担がかかると
で 心臓病にはもうなる体質だと
あるいは脳梗塞になるんだと
とわかったら それは変えられませんだからその人は一生
まあ体にいい和食で生活すればいいでしょうに
なんで私の運が悪いんでしょうかとかね
朝も昼もハンバーガー食べてステーキ食べて生活したいのに
なんとかないんですか？それは変える方法というのはないんですね
その人はやっぱりまあハンバーガーとステーキやら
そんなものはやめて 海苔とご飯と食べて
生活すればいいんですよ
だから納得いく 満足いくということは聞かない
こんなわがままは成り立ちません
みんなわがままだからむちゃくちゃになっているんですよ
そう好き勝手に感覚は変わらないんだから
わがままを捨てて 科学的にその状況に合わせてみる
わがままは科学的な世界では成り立ちません
運転免許を持っていないんだけど
車を運転したいんだと
そんなわがまま言ったら
貸してください 自分も乗って
車を教習所に一回も行ったことがない人に
例えば自分の子供がお父さん
私にも運転やらせてやらせてという時は
自分の我が子だから可愛いでしょ
交代してあげてください
車の運転 どうなるんですかね
だから子供は運転できない
小さな子供で 車の中でどういう風に
あの もうなんて言いますか
過激行動しても 運転は変えるわけにはいきませんでしょうね
黙ってなさいよと あまりにももうもうむちゃくちゃわがまま言っちゃうと
もうそこら辺で落としてやるぞとかね
落としてお父さんとお母さんだけ帰るぞと
そういう風な脅しでもして抑えてもらうしか方法ないんですよ
だから科学世界ではわがままはは通用しません
運転したい人はちゃんと訓練を受けて免許を取らなくちゃいけない
それは変えることはできません
それで法律的にはになっていないと免許は取れない
そういうことだから もう科学的な世界ではわがままは全く通用しないということを理解して
自分がもう例えばもうステーキばっかり食いたいんだからといって
体に合うか合わないかということはまず考えてほしいんですよ
自分が交通便利な町の真ん中に生活したいとわがままで思ったっても
その生活 自分の体に性格に合うか合わないかと
だから決してわがままは通用しない
だから 業の場合 みんなわがまま
何か通じてくれるかなとか考えているでしょうと思いますけど
それはない それは置いておいて
論理的に科学的に考えると
不幸な業も苦しみにならないように入れ替えることはできます
肺が悪い弱い肺で生まれても
死ぬまで健康でいられます
肺が悪くて もうそれほど命が長くないと言われても
大丈夫 すごい綺麗な空気があるところに引っ越しするんだよと
全く車入らないところに生活するそうと
買い物にはキロを歩いて行くところにいるんだよと風にすればいいんですよ
そうすると長生きはできますが
買い物にはキロ歩かなくちゃいけないんです
そうやってもいろいろ
あまり悪いのはないんですけど
人生は苦ということはもう避けられないんだからね
そういうふうに入れ替えるということはできます
そこで まあもう一つのポイントで気を付け出します
このウェーデナの場合はこれを理解してください
ウェーデナは 3つあります
あの スカドッカウペッカーと
スカドッカウペッカ スカっていうのは楽という
楽しいという感覚 ドッカは楽しくない苦という感覚
で これは楽 これは苦 ウペッカーっていうのは
まあどちらにでも言えない感覚
漢文にする場合は こちらに楽という漢字を書きます
こちらには苦という漢字を書きます
こちらには不苦不楽と書くんです
で まあ何ですかね ウペッカーという漢字がないということは
ノーマル普通という感覚
まあ苦 苦しい感覚とも言えないし
楽しい感覚とも言えない
中立的な感覚はウペッカーなんですね
一応大きく感覚 そうやって 3つに分けられます
例えば音の場合は 楽しい音の場合は皆様方はいろんなことを言うでしょ？音楽とかね
で また聞きたくない音もありますね
聞くと気持ち悪くなる音もあります
これ 音なんです 言葉ではないんです
例えば 自分を叱ると聞きたくないでしょうね
その場合は言葉聞きたくないんですよ
母親がものすごく叱ると
子供は嫌で嫌でも聞きたくないんですね
その場合は 母の言葉が嫌であって
声が嫌わけじゃないんですよ
母の声は子供はものすごい落ち着くんです
だから その場合はそういうふうに理解してほしいんですよ
音といっても言葉ではないと
そういうことで 気持ちいい音がありまして
気持ち悪い音があって
どちらでもない音もありますね
そうやって感覚が 3つあります
そこで人間がいろんな行為をする
歩いたり 座ったり 立ったり
喋ったり 仕事をしたり
行為をしている 人間の全ての行為は心が自分でやらせているんです
足が一度も自分勝手で歩くことはないんです
当たり前のことですけど
不思議によく中それ知らないんですよ
足が勝手に歩くこともないし
手が勝手に人を殴ることはないし
私はそういうことを時々言いますけど
人を子供とか殴っちゃってね
この手が悪いんだよと
と言ってごまかすんですけど
私は知りませんと まあ子供はそれは明らかに嘘だと知ってますからね
まあそれでまあ一応ごまかせますけどね
でも決して自分の手が勝手に上がって
勝手に人の体にぶつけるということはないんです
そういうことだから 歩く時もやっぱり行為であって
それは心がやっています
手を上げることも行為であって
喋ったりすることも ご飯作ることも
仕事をすることも あらゆる行為は心がやっています
いくらか物質的 物質的な行為もあるんですが
例えば  まあなんとか病気ありますね
あれ なんていいますか
パーキンソンとかね その場合はこの神経と脳の異常があって
こうやって手足やら動いて震えたりするとかね
その場合は意識は関係ないんですね
心はもう止まりたいんだけど
この機械が調子が悪いんですね
そうやって我々は何か高いところで何かやろうと思っちゃうと
まあ椅子 まあ脚立がちょっと滑っちゃって倒れるとかね
じゃあこれから倒れますよと思って倒れるわけじゃないんですね
そういうのは物質的なことで
まあまああんまり難しくない
わかりやすいもんですよ
倒れそうと思って自分で意思で倒れると怪我しないでしょ
怪我するのは意識がなく倒れる時なんですよ
例えば海岸で海岸 階段で転がろうと思いましょう
わざとゴロゴロと転がっちゃって
一階まで落ちても全然
まあちょっとかすり傷はあるかもしれませんけど
怪我しないんですよ それで足が弱くて滑っちゃったと
階段で そしたらもうあっちこっち六股
もう折れる骨は全部折れるんです
そんなもんです ですから
心の働きっていうのは大変な大したもんですよ
わざと落ちると怪我しない
火でも触ってみてください
わざと 火傷しないよ でも不注意で
火に触れたら焼けます
そういうふうにしっかり心は不思議な働きをしています
それで行為するときは
我々はまた感覚で行為するんですよ
そこで結果は苦しい感覚の行為をすると苦しい結果になると
楽しい感覚の行為をすると楽しい結果になるんだと
不幸 不楽の感覚の行為をすると
その同じ結果になるんだっていうのは
お釈迦様はそれが業の方程式なんですよ
またいくつかありますけど
それは分かりやすい世界に戻ってみましょう
私は人を殴る 殴られる側はどんな感覚を受けますか？すごい苦しい感覚を受けるんですよ
それで殴ってる最中 殴る人も痛いんですよ
そんな気持ちいいものじゃないんです
殴る愛場合は 殴る側がすごく気持ちよくて
最高に気持ちよくて 殴られる側だけ痛いんだったら
みんなもうとっくに殺されています
管理できなくなります
だって殴れば殴るほどこちらが刺激的で楽しくてたまらんでしょうに
だから死ぬまで殴っちゃうんです
一人もいないと思いますよ
それだったら だから喧嘩する場合は
強い人も弱い人も痛いのは痛いんですよ
そこで喧嘩を売った人が責任多いでしょうに
殴った人は責任持たなくちゃあかんですよ
殴られた人よりも それで私は人を殴って
相手にすごい苦しい感覚を作ったんですよ
それは心の法則によって
行為には確実に結果がある
ですから 確実に自分が苦しい感覚生まれるように
自分の感覚システムが変わるんです
それからがあるんです
だからそれで人がお腹が空いて
もうもう死にそうになっている
私はその人にすごいおいしいごちそうを作って
これを食べてくださいと
心配して優しい言葉もかけてね
こんな大変でしょう お腹が空いてね
やっぱりおいしい おいしくご飯食べましょうと言って
穏やかな気持ちにさせてご飯食べさせてあげる
そうすると その人はどんな感覚を受けますか？お腹が空いてもう死にそうな人がおいしいご飯を食べて
優しい言葉も聞いて ものすごい幸福感じるでしょ
それ 自分が責任でやったことでしょうに
それで自分もそういうふうになんと幸福かというふうに感じられるように
自分の感覚システムが変わるんです
それが仏教が語る業論なんです
それでそれ あの具体的な例だけ
人にご飯をあげたらすごい徳がありますよ
そればっかり取っちゃうと
なんだこれとわからなくなっちゃいますよ
人にご飯だったら自分の食べるものなくなるだけではないかどうかね
お布施したら幸福になります
と言ったら なんだこれとお布施で自分持ってるお金がなくなるだけではないかと
だから そう取ること自体が間違いんですよ
そんな単純な話じゃないんです
はっきりした論理的な
具体的な話なんです だから当然人を助けてあげたら自分が幸福になります
どれぐらいかとハッキリ測ってみたければ
相手がどれぐらいそれで喜びを感じたかと
それやりながら自分がどれぐらい喜びを感じたかと
それ足してみれば それ結果なんです
例えば うるさい この人はもうお腹も空いちゃって
もう今の時期 時間 時代
時間で私も忙しいなのにとかね
これで文句言いながら
嫌で嫌でどうしようもない
まあいいだ もう食べなさいよとかね
とあげる その行為と ああ
大変でしょう もう早く
ちょっと待ってください
すぐおいしいご飯作ってあげますからと
と言って すごく気持ちよく
自分がものすごくニコニコと鼻歌でも歌いながら
もう楽しくてすごくごちそうを作って
どうぞどうぞ食べてくださいと
穏やかな気持ちで食べさせると
その ２つ考えてみてください
単純にわかるでしょう？どちらの方が効き目が高いかと
1番目の場合は 自分が嫌で嫌でしようがないもうどうしようもないもう
という気持ちで 自分が苦しみを感じながら相手に幸福を味わせる
そうすると幸福から苦しみを引いて
残りが自分の結果なんです
2番目の場合は足してみるんですね
引くものはないんですね
そういうふうに淡々と
仏教でまたわかりやすく
一般の人々 論理わからない人々に
一般的に あの 何ていうのは
清らかな心で 明るい心で
楽しい気持ちでお布施しなさい
人を助けてみなさいと
そうすると あなたは何
何億倍もその幸福になりますよという話をするんです
それだけきちんとちょん切っちゃって
カットしてあっちこっち持っていったら
これがもうむちゃくちゃになるんです
その裏ですごい話があるんです
だから人を助けたら神様が喜んで幸福にしてするぞという世界の話と
我々の話はものすごく違う
似ているんだけど 似てないんです
全く似てないんです どんな宗教でも苦しんでいる人を助けなさいと言ってますよ
それこそもう神様が喜ぶ行為だよと
仏教も言ってますよ だから同じやと
そんな無責任なことは言ってほしくない
ちゃんと勉強してほしいと
世界は違うんだよと ブッダが語ることは誰も語っていないんだと
そういうことで 感覚で業のからくりを仏教で説明しています
次は後でちょっと休憩いたしまして続けます
どうもありがとうございます